she last took to the sky one year ago
performing a fly pass celebrating
ukraine's independence day now she lies
in ruins on this airfield
mechanism vladimir smooth scours the
wreckage for recognizable pieces of the
maria the plane that made antonov a
world famous aviation company the
gigantic plane lies in sections and
staff are scattered around salvaging
parts
along with the antonov spokesperson
global news was granted a rare view from
inside yeah
he says i just came here for the first
time the site is overwhelming the maria
was the world's largest cargo plane
holding more than 100 world records
including the heaviest payload ever
lifted brazil
employees do not really like to be
photographed in front of the background
of the destroyed maria the rebuilding
effort is underway it's a priority for
the company and the nation but what
happened at this site is under
investigation by ukrainian authorities
russian forces targeted the antonov
airport on day one of the invasion
the helicopters flew at extremely low
altitudes rose from behind the forest
belt and opened fire on the object of
zantonov airport
as he watched paratroopers drop onto the
airfield he gave the order to return
fire kalia
when i see all destroyed russian
equipment it makes me happy the
ukrainians he says were dominated from
the air without artillery support they
were soon outnumbered and forced to pull
back the maria was just one of the
casualties of the fierce and bloody
battle that raged here for weeks ukraine
eventually reclaimed the area
we were not prepared for war they
figured some missile strikes were
possible but not an invasion of the
airfield
widely shared video shows russian forces
seizing the airport and all of the
buildings but for this long time
employee the video isn't necessary
he was there that day is that this
building
so those staircases
yes it's believed the goal was to create
a russian base within striking distance
of keith the main administration
building here at the airport is pretty
much destroyed this was the air traffic
control tower as you can see there's
really not much left of any of it
russian forces stormed this
administration building they use the
control tower area as a lookout point
from here they could not only see the
airfield but also hostimel
european
and over that way butcher as russian
forces arrived civilians nearby suffered
tremendously as russians were unable to
push forward to the capitol homes were
looted in the region people were beaten
killed
or taken hostage rudenko says some of
his men who defended the airport remain
in captivity he wouldn't say how many
what he did say about the russian
captors
is unsparing
all of you will be in fire
the emotions fueled the desire to
rebuild the maria bigger and better a
new symbol of ukraine and its endurance
crystal gomanson global news hostomel
ukraine